DAVE SMITH: The
Internet of Things
promises big opportunities
for developers
to contribute to the huge growth
of devices hitting the market.
But have you ever
stopped to think
about what it really
takes to build
a connected product at scale?
My name is Dave
Smith, and today, I'm
going to show you how
Android Things can
help you build smart,
connected devices for IoT.
Android Things is an
extension of Android designed
to enable developers
to build high quality,
secure devices, and
maintain them at scale.
The platform is made up
of three core elements--
a variant of Android that
has been optimized for use
in IoT, secure and managed
updates direct from Google,
and powerful hardware
that's accessible and easy
to integrate.
Let's begin with the software
running on the device.
With Android Things,
you can build
apps using the rich framework
provided by the Android SDK
and Google Play services,
including the same UI
toolkit, multimedia support,
and connectivity APIs used
by mobile developers today.
Your apps can easily integrate
with popular Google services,
like Firebase, TensorFlow,
and the Google Cloud Platform
using the many existing
Android client libraries.
And of course, you can develop
using all the same languages
and tools supported for
Android development today.
To improve the Android
experience for embedded use,
we've tuned the platform for
faster boot times and lower
memory footprint,
including a smaller
variant of Google Play services
optimized specifically for IoT.
We've also added new APIs
through the Android Things
support library to
better integrate
your apps with custom hardware.
This includes expanded support
for peripheral interfaces
and device management.
Android things does not
include user-facing apps,
like a launcher or browser.
Instead, it is designed
to boot directly
into the apps you've
built for your device.
Google takes care of
providing updates and security
patches to the core
operating system
so you can focus on your app.
This means you get to take
advantage of our ongoing work
on Android to keep your devices
secure and protect your users.
System images are
signed by Google
and verified for
integrity on device.
This prevents a corrupt
or tampered update
from being applied.
Android's seamless
A/B updates apply
the image in the background
without interrupting
the application.
Failure to boot
following an update
will roll back to
the previous version,
ensuring the system always
boots into a known good state.
Updates are delivered
over the air
from the Android
Things console using
the same secure
infrastructure we use
to update mobile devices today.
We can even push
updates automatically
when security patches are
available for the platform.
Apps on the device are managed
exclusively through the console
and bundled with each update.
This means that
Android Things does not
include the Google Play Store
because user-installed apps are
not supported.
Building production
devices with Android Things
is a turnkey process thanks to
the system on module, or SoM,
architecture.
Each module is a fully
integrated component
that you can drop directly
into your final design
the same way you would
integrate a framework
or library into your app.
Modules are manufactured in
high volume by the chip vendors,
enabling you to purchase
them at low cost
whether you need to
buy 1, 10, or 10,000.
Android Things hardware
is pre-certified by Google
with a board support
package provided
by our vendor partners.
These partnerships enable us
to deliver long-term support
for each stable release across
our entire hardware lineup.
The hardware is
also pre-certified
with regulatory
agencies, like the FCC,
simplifying the certification
testing required
to take your product to
market and further saving you
time and money.
Android Things is so
much more than just
a cool new form factor
for building your apps.
Secure system updates
and accessible hardware
make it a reliable platform
for connected devices at scale.
To learn more about
how to get started,
visit the documentation
and check out our samples
and drivers on GitHub.
Also, join our community
so you can ask questions,
share your projects, and stay
up-to-date with the latest
platform announcements.
Thanks so much for
watching today,
and I look forward
to seeing what
you build with Android Things.
I'm Dave Smith, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]